sam i know you love the nba i know you
love hoops
do you love talking about the lakers as
much as you probably have to talk about
them these days
uh yeah no complaints on the the laker
talk i mean listen if you're in the
media as you can relate to
the bigger the fan base the more folks
are are enjoying the commentary and the
coverage so uh yeah no problems there
got to play the hits sometimes well let
me ask you then about the lakers
and the concern here with the injury
situation obviously anthony davis has
been out for a while
uh lebron's gonna be out probably for
around a month or so
do you anticipate them making a move
maybe trying to add a little shooting
here before the trade deadline on
thursday
i mean i'm sure they're gonna be active
they're pretty limited though and what
they're able to do
they're pretty close to their hard cap
they
they don't have the kinds of pieces that
i think that they're willing to move out
in terms of their bigger picture
that's in play the the you know the
title defense and and the idea that
once lebron and a.d get back you know
you can't be
losing a uh a dennis schruter or
montrose herald anybody like that
who might not be able to help carry you
now but is going to come in handy
and you hope they'll be part of that
championship picture
once you're whole again so you know
you hear consistently them tied to
uh rim protection is is javel mcgee
gonna come back
somebody like that um you know now of
course they they could use
you know players with a kind of a more
versatile skill set
because of the injury stuff but i'd be
surprised if they really found any
real legitimate answers on that front in
the next two days maybe somebody on the
buyout market like andre drummond could
end up
you know like oh sure yeah yeah andre is
one that
you know he's gonna certainly be uh
sought after quite a bit
if that buy on ends up happening and it
probably will i mean i think he's around
30 million with his his cavs deal so
the big would be my focus with them uh
and then just kind of trying to tread
water
you know i have this theory everybody's
worried that they have to
you know they fall down to a seven or an
eight seed and they have to
do the whole play-in deal to get into
the tournament i almost think that
if i'm lebron that makes the story even
better
if they were able to win again right
sure i mean if they were able to win
again 100 i
you know i don't know i mean yeah it'd
be a great storyline
um but and far be it from me to every
question the guy who
keeps showing us that that's a bad idea
but 36 year old lebron coming off a
a serious ankle injury you know having
to then
take out an elite western conference
team in the first round
you know and fight your way kind of up
the championship mountain from there
to me the west is is loaded enough and
there's enough parity that
you know if you were asking me to bet uh
you know on the lakers or the field
in that scenario i'd probably be betting
on the field it would be hard
but but certainly would make the story
better so trade deadline coming up
thursday
um aaron gordon being shopped um
kyle lowry uh could be on the move from
toronto uh marvin bagley as you alluded
to in one of the articles
uh the kings have not found any any
takers for him yet
um what what are a couple of moves or
trades that you expect to happen here
before the trade deadline
well the the gordon situation has been a
focal point of mine we wrote about
the situation with boston the other day
and and
the kind of revelation that aaron asked
for a trade
last month um you know formally and
i think that will happen uh i think
right now i would still handicap
boston as the the leader but denver is
definitely in the mix
and definitely wants aaron and it's kind
of that you know now
it's that game the cat and mouse game of
but there's still time on the clock and
like the nuggets for instance
don't want to be too desperate they
don't feel like they have to make a move
the celtics have a ton of pressure on
them you know playing 500 basketball
when you have
two all-stars who are used to being in
the conference finals is not a good
equation
and so i'm curious to see where that
goes i think if aaron moves
it's going to be one of those two teams
you know larry
i thought kyle was going to stay put
because his money is so hard to match 30
million dollars on an expiring deal
but you know there is a lot of noise
about philly and miami
and the clippers have been interested
but but now they you know they can't get
their money wise
so you know kyle's another one and
staying in toronto
or tampa to be more specific uh norman
powell is another guy
with a ton of teams chasing him and and
i think is gonna
be a nice addition to uh to probably a
contender so
i think we're gonna have a bunch of like
you know kind of second and third tier
guys
probably get moved as you know dan it's
it's not a superstar trade deadline
season
you know after the harden trade went
down there's really nobody else out
there
of that caliber but i think it'll be
active
speaking of superstars um brooklyn
the team to beat i mean once they're
healthy and once they have
all the parts there do you see anybody
being able to take them down
i don't know i mean i kind of love how
wide open it is because yeah there's
moments when you say
yeah how do you beat that trio well for
one that trio has barely been together
now you got kyrie missing games for
family reasons
you know having another absence the
durant injury
obviously is a problem you feel for
kevin mann he spent so much time on the
sideline last couple years
and now to have to go through it again
you know and even james has been banged
up so
you know i'm not sold on them as the
title front runner
here's the funny part to me is like
we're guilty
in the media of being very narrative
driven and so
milwaukee jumps out because it's like i
feel like in the media we've
unofficially decided that
that giannis can't be the back to back
to back mvp
just because they fell short in the
playoffs but he
uh you know had been playing well before
he got a little bit
banged up as well but you know the bucks
are a team that i think we're sleeping
on again
and and giannis in particular in his mvp
candidacy
but i mean there's you know the utah
clippers lakers all the way down the
line
philly um i really i probably have
recency bias a little bit but i feel
like
you know more than in past years it's
just really wide open but
brooklyn's the most compelling team from
the standpoint of we love
super teams and and monitoring whether
or not they can maximize
their incredible talent and so i'm
hoping in that vein
that the nets are healthy when the
playoff time comes around because i
really want to see
if they can have chemistry and if they
can go out and be the team that
that we think they might be able to be
yeah so do i i mean it's an incredible
collection of talent they have there
in brooklyn speaking of maximizing
potential i feel like lonzo balls
is closer to maximizing potential and
he's in line to get a much bigger payday
than we anticipated that he would be
getting
a couple of years ago i saw yesterday or
the day before
where michael thompson klay thompson's
dad who
uh calls lakers games on the radio said
i'd love to see lonzo
end up in golden state is that something
you could see coming to fruition
i could yeah it is there's like a
leveling out of the longview market
happening
where you know phase one was the
incredibly over
hyped opening with lavar you know
telling the world that
lonzo was going to be the next coming of
of you know steve nash combined with
with uh you know gary payton and chris
paul and all the best point guards of
all time
um magic johnson chief among them and
and that was just too much and so lonzo
couldn't
live up to that but now that he's
getting closer to free agency
and you know that he has developed and
really his
defensive side of the ball and his
ability to
to play both guard positions has made
him a nice fit
and for a lot of teams and that has a
lot to do with all the interest because
if it's atlanta
right and they look at it and they go
yeah you know what i think lonzo can
maybe play with trey if it's the
warriors
you know and you have a healthy clay
thompson with steph and lonzo
as a three guard set i mean that would
be pretty dangerous and
and so to lonzo's credit he's checking a
lot more boxes as a player
that i think you know coming out of uh
you know in the beginning it was all
about his play-making and that was it
um he in his camp want
and kind of expect to be getting around
20 million dollars a year
in free agency that's kind of the word
among teams that are interested and so
you know that's kind of the unofficial
price tag you have to consider
but uh but yeah i mean i don't know the
warriors have that
that you know that draft pick that is
the most valuable asset in the league
right now and so
you know i i doubt they'd be willing to
give up something like that for lonzo
but uh if they were able to get him i
think he he certainly would uh would
take them to a new level
yeah he's averaging career highs and in
points and three-point field goal
percentage become a much better shooter
uh since he entered the league speaking
of the draft
obviously you've been watching the ncaa
tournament like the rest of us who's
who's popped who have you noticed that
it's going to be a
a difference maker then i got to be
honest with you brother i'm just going
to own it i have not been diving in i've
been in trade mode
um i don't know what it is you know i
mean we we had a good time on
my podcast yesterday uh joking about
cade cunningham one of my co-hosts
anthony slater is an oklahoma state alum
and and he was dishing a little bit of
kate cunningham slander and saying that
he thought he might be
a little over hyped so that's kind of
been the extent of my ncaa focus
i just know that i mean if through the
nba lens
um you know the idea that you could have
you know in the neighborhood of five
franchise-changing
type players is you know it's coloring
decisions that are happening right now
and that that part has always been
really interesting to me because
you know you got teams in real time
deciding are we going to tank are we
going to go for it and try to sneak into
the playoffs what are we going to do
and that calculus is tied you know
to not only the draft but then now in
real time with the tournament
you know like you said who's topping and
who's not so you know that's going to
have a ripple effect uh
you know but admittedly i probably
should uh start diving a little bit more
and watching the action right now well
probably not a fair question for you
with the trade deadline coming up so
believe me i completely understand a
little busy during football season
it's certainly all about football for me
and i'm not watching as much college as
i do
uh nfl no doubt about that uh the kate
cunningham stuff is interesting because
i think he's a nice player but man
mobley
has really been impressive from what i
have seen uh in the tournament and the
other thing that's really fascinating
to me dan helly sitting up for rich
eisen uh talking to sam amick senior nba
writer from the atlantic
is what's happening with the g league
and the the players now who are choosing
to go to the g league instead of
overseas or instead of college for a
year
and this new program that they have
where they can pay them half a million
dollars
and they can sign shoe deals and they're
going to be developed and play against
solid competition
how has that been uh looked at this year
has it been
already designated a success
i think the answer is yes but then the
the kind of assert
is that the pandemic made things i mean
it made things hard on everybody but it
it really impacted the g league quite a
bit now they did pull off the g league
bubble
and kind of made the best of a
challenging situation but
by and large uh 100 the
reputation of the g-league and
previously known as the d-league
has changed in the kind of way that it
it's a whole lot closer to being a
baseball style
minor league system now than ever
because
it's funny i mean i've covered the
league roughly for
i guess 17 years now and you know in the
beginning
um when a player got assigned to the
d-league
i mean it was like getting assigned from
a pro team back to a college team i mean
you were
you know guys would probably you know
more likely to just quit and try some
other avenue than they were to take that
assignment
and feel okay about it it was not the jv
team
it was something even worse than that so
now
you have guys that if they're not
getting enough burn
with their nba team i mean you even hear
stories about
guys saying could you put me on
assignment down with the geely team let
me
actually go and prove and you know
there's not that that uh that complex
about that path so yeah it's a
legitimate thing and they you know they
were smart enough to know that
money makes the world go around and
you've got to incentivize these guys
to to get paid real basketball money as
opposed to the
you know i mean in the beginning it was
like 25 000 annual stipends
right to go play in the d league and
it's it's on a whole different level now
well they have that ignite team now and
you look at some of these mock drafts
and
uh you have jalen green who's going to
be a top four top five pick jonathan
kamingai i believe i'm saying that
correctly and both those guys
uh in in the g league you know as
teenagers so um certainly that yeah and
you got the coaching aspect too
you know with with brian shaw people
like that being part of it as
credibility you know former head coaches
so uh yeah it's really i mean listen all
around the league
um they they're they're kind of a more
comprehensive robust
system now than they were even 10 15
years ago yeah certainly coming a long
way sam amex senior nba writer from the
athletics sam thank you so much for
joining us appreciate the time my man
you got it dan thanks man hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here